ver el vídeo completo antes de quitar su
bomba
este video le enseñará Cómo saber si la
bomba funciona Cómo realizar el
mantenimiento Y cómo quitarla
una bomba para el dolor se usa después
de una cirugía para proporcionar un
medicamento anestésico directamente en
el área en la que se operó el
medicamento adormece los nervios cerca
de su incisión para que tenga menos
dolor
el medicamento fluye continua y
lentamente desde la bomba a través de un
tubo pequeño colocado debajo de la piel
cerca de la incisión quirúrgica El
pequeño tubo denominado catéter se
conecta la bomba
y se fija una abrazadera y un filtro
junto con el tubo
puede usar una pequeña bolsa para
sostener la bomba para que pueda
realizar sus actividades diarias
[Música]
la bomba le suministra un medicamento
anestésico con la dosis indicada por su
cirujano la dosis en la bomba no se
puede modificar
recibirá el medicamento durante 2 a 4
días
cuando la bomba esté vacía retire el
tubo
y deseche la bomba y el tubo
[Música]
Cómo detectar si la bomba para el dolor
funciona
la bomba suministra medicamento tan
lentamente que no se puede ver cómo se
mueve en el tubo podría tomar entre 24 y
48 horas antes de que Note un cambio en
el tamaño y aspecto de la bola
puedes saber que la bomba funciona así
su sitio quirúrgico se siente adormecido
y el medicamento reduce el dolor
la bola se reduce cada vez más
y la bolsa externa en la bomba queda más
floja y comienza a arrugarse la bomba
está vacía cuando la bolsa queda plana y
usted siente un tubo duro en el medio
esto Generalmente ocurre a las 48 y 72
horas
cuidado de la bomba para el dolor
revise la bomba para el dolor varias
veces por día para asegurarse de que la
abrazadera esté abierta y se deslice
fácilmente nada cubra el filtro
y que el tubo no esté Doblado ni torcido
si la bomba o los tubos presentan
pérdidas si era la abrazadera y llame a
su cirujano
si el tubo se separa de la bomba no
vuelva a conectarlo
cierre la abrazadera y llame a su
cirujano
si el tubo se sale de la piel no vuelva
a colocarlo
cierre la abrazadera y llame a su
cirujano
[Música]
también debe cerrar la abrazadera en el
tubo y Llamar a su cirujano Se observa
lo siguiente le timbran o zumban los
oídos visión borrosa sabor a metal en la
boca
entumecimiento u hormigueo en los dedos
dedos de los pies o alrededor de la boca
se siente somnoliento o confundido
más dolor
fiebre escalofríos o sudores problemas
para respirar color rojizo hinchazón
calor o dolor alrededor del sitio donde
ingresa el tubo en la piel hemorragia o
pérdida desde el sitio del tubo mareos o
aturdimiento
asegúrese de proteger la bomba el filtro
y el tubo del agua no tome un baño de
inmersión ni coloque la bomba bajo agua
y asegúrese de seguir las instrucciones
del cirujano con respecto a cómo bañarse
al dormir mantenga la bomba dentro de la
bolsa pequeña y colócala junto a usted
encima de las sábanas esto ayuda a
mantener el tubo flojo en lugar no
coloque la bomba debajo de la ropa de
cama en el suelo ni la cuelgue desde
algún lugar
[Música]
materiales para retirar la bomba
para quitar la bomba para el dolor
necesitará lo siguiente Una venda
adhesiva y una bolsa de basura
retiro de la bomba
paso uno lávese las manos con agua y
jabón y luego sé que las
paso 2 suavemente afloje la venda
alrededor del sitio donde ingresa el
tubo en la piel quite la lentamente
despegándola
paso 3 quite la cinta que se usa para
fijar el tubo en su lugar
paso 4 sostenga el tubo cerca de la piel
jale el tubo suavemente en un ángulo de
90 grados
no jale ni tire fuerte el tubo debería
salir fácilmente si se siente duro para
quitar o se estira deténgase y llame a
su cirujano si sigues jalando podría
romper el tubo
paso 5 después de que salga el tubo
revise si la punta tiene una marca negra
para asegurarse de que retiró el tubo
entero llame a su cirujano si no ve la
marca negra
[Música]
paso 6 cubra el sitio donde ingresaba el
tubo en su piel con una venda adhesiva
paso 7 deseche el tubo la bomba y las
vendas en una bolsa de residuo
revisión del sitio de entrada del tubo
al día siguiente
[Música]
paso 1 lávese nuevamente las manos y
luego sé que las
paso 2 quite la venda adhesiva al
siguiente día y Observa el sitio
si presenta un color rojizo dolor o
calor en el sitio llame a su cirujano
[Música]